this is Ari tuna the world's first
recycled mall as in everything sold here
is second-hand recycled or repurposed
manager Anna Bergstrom hopes it can
begin to channel humanity's rampant
consumerism or at least Sweden's in a
more sustainable direction this is the
future way to run a shopping mall I
guess and any business in the future
needs to be sustainable to to last s
kills tunas waste plant processes 20,000
tons of rubbish a year with smart
cameras pointing different materials in
the right direction food waste is sold
back to residences compost or used to
power s kills tunas buses and provide
heating for the town but there's a side
project they hope will have a global
impact breeding larvae from the black
soldier fly as a protein source for
salmon farms to get the protein and we
get the manure from the larvae that is
perfect for the improving of the soil so
it's a win-win for everyone
REE tuna has also helped heal some of
the hurt of eskilstuna 's high
unemployment yeah I love to paint change
the fittings fix things it's perfect for
me because I've had so many jobs in my
life now I'd love to work with this very
old furniture sql's tuners recycled
future has not replaced its former steel
industry with 15,000 still unemployed in
a city of 100,000 we could just lay down
and give up what we chose to to not we
were still proud of being a
manufacturing town but we're also trying
to find new ways and combine them put
together green policies have given this
city the chance to recycle its image
after a loss of industry and identity
the question is whether it remains an
outpost in the war against climate
change or a blueprint for the rest of
the world to adopt polarise al Jazeera
eskilstuna Sweden